WHITE HOUSE OF BARACK OBAMA.
AND THE VICE PRESIDENT'S OFFICE,
JOE BIDEN.
HERE WITH MORE, JUDICIAL WATCH
PRESIDENT TOM FITTON, TO ME THIS
IS A BREAKTHROUGH.
WE HAVE AND ASKING THE QUESTION
HOW HIGH UP, WE KNOW THAT THE
DEEP STATE ACTORS ARE NOW
TURNING ON EACH OTHER, PAIGE,
STRZOK ARE POINTING THE FINGER
AT THEN ATTORNEY GENERAL LORETTA
LYNCH.
AND WE HAVE JAMES BAKER SAYING I
KNEW FROM THE BEGINNING THIS WAS
A BAD IDEA.
THEN YOU HAVE THE DEPUTY FBI
DIRECTOR McCABE SAYING WE
WOULD NOT HAVE GOTTEN A FISA
WARRANTS WITHOUT THE DOSSIER,
THE DIRTY DOSSIER.
THE UNVERIFIABLE DOSSIER.
AND THEN YOU HAVE BRENNAN AND
CLAPPER HATING COMEY.
HE AND COMEY McCABE GOING AT
EACH OTHER.
SO I WOULD ASSUME BETWEEN ALL OF
THE INFIGHTING AND
FINGER-POINTING AND NOW WHAT IS
A CIVIL WAR AND CIRCULATORY
FIRING SQUAD, WE WILL GET TO THE
TRUTH FINALLY.
>> WELL, CERTAINLY NOW WE NEED
TO EXPAND THE INVESTIGATION INTO
THE OBAMA STATE DEPARTMENT,
JONATHAN WEINER WHO WAS CLOSE TO
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
THE LIBYA EXPERT FOR JOHN KERRY
STATE DEPARTMENT WAS SHEPHERDING
STEELE AND ACTUALLY HELPING HIM
WRITE THE DOSSIER OR A PART OF
IT THAT WAS LAUNDERED INTO THE
FBI AND JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
THE STEELE DOSSIER WAS WRITTEN
IN PART, ACCORDING TO THE OP-ED
IN "THE WASHINGTON POST," HE
ADMITTED THAT HE HELPED WRITE A
SUMMARY OF OTHER MATERIAL HE WAS
GETTING FROM THE CLINTON GANG
AND WATERED IT THROUGH STEELE TO
THE DOJ AND FBI.
IT SHOWS HE WAS IN COMMUNICATION
WITH VICTORIA NEWLIN AND THEY
WANTED TO MEET ABOUT THE RUSSIAN
MATTER.
WE WERE SUING FOR RUSSIA GATE
DOCUMENTS RELATED TO STEELE.
WE KNOW IT IS ABOUT THAT.
AND THIS MEETING TOOK PLACE
ALMOST SIMULTANEOUSLY WITH A
MEANING THAT GLENN SIMPSON HAD
WITH THE STATE DEPARTMENT ABOUT
TO RUSSIA GAIT AS WELL.
REMEMBER VICTORIA NULAND HAD THE
MEETINGS BETWEEN THE FBI AND
CHRISTOPHER STEELE IN THE U.K.
OF THE SUMMER OF 2016, AND OTHER
DOCUMENTS SHOW THAT SHE WAS
WORKING WITH THE OFFICE TO GET
THE RUSH OF MATERIAL THROUGH.
AND PUSHING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION TO MAKE TRUMP LOOK
BAD JUST BEFORE THE
INAUGURATION.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT IS AT THE
CENTER OF THE STORM IN TERMS OF
THE ABUSES OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION AGAINST THEN
CANDIDATE TRUMP, AND THE
INCOMING PRESIDENT MR. TRUMP.
>> Sean: WE KNOW THIS, THAT
BRUCE OHR AND KATHLEEN X ALL
WARNED ABOUT THE DOSSIER BOUGHT
AND PARRIED FOR, AND
UNVERIFIABLE, STEELE'S AGENDA
BEFORE THE FIRST FISA WARNED
APPLICATION WHEN IN.
AT THE TOP OF THE FISA WARRANTS
ITS IS VERIFIED.
THEN JOHN SOLOMON'S REPORT WHICH
IS THE FBI HAD THEIR OWN
SPREADSHEET, EVEN THEY KNEW THAT
TO 90% OF IT WAS GARBAGE, SO
THEN ON TOP OF THIS, NOW WE ARE
SEEING JUST HOW HIGH UP IT GOES,
DO YOU THINK WE GET TO THE
QUESTION OF WHEN DID OBAMA KNOW
IT?
SPEAK OF THE MEETING OCCURRED
BEFORE COMEY WENT AND AMBUSHED
THEN CANDIDATE TRUMP WITH THE
DOSSIER OF JANUARY 2017.
THERE WAS AN OVAL OFFICE MEETING
WHERE COMEY BROUGHT UP THE
DOSSIER WITH MR. OBAMA,
MR. BIDEN, SUSAN RICE WAS THERE.
AND I THINK BRENNAN WAS THERE.
AND THEY ALL DISCUSS THE
DOSSIER.
SUSAN RICE WAS THERE AS WELL.
OBAMA KNEW ABOUT THE DOSSIER AND
THE TEXT MESSAGES BETWEEN STRZOK
AND PAGE.
THE WHITE HOUSE WANTED TO KNOW
ABOUT THIS.
WHEN IT CAME TO GOING AFTER
TRUMP ON THE DOSSIER AND THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION IT WAS ALL
HANDS ON DECK AND WAS
ORCHESTRATED OUT OF THE
WHITE HOUSE.
AND I THINK THE BIG ISSUE IS FOR
THE MEDIA AND INVESTIGATORS, WHY
ISN'T PRESIDENT OBAMA BEING
ASKED TO SERIOUS QUESTIONS ABOUT
THIS?